I watched your new film Argy it's so
good it looked so fun when I saw the
trailer I was like oh I'm seeing this
it's really fun it's really fun it's a
real roller coaster I loved it really
good good it is so fun and I mean this
in the most platonic way Sam and I never
dated I'm lesie I love you you are sexy
in this movie you're very sexy in this
movie like thank you it's so funny cuz
you start theil and a beard and long
hair and then all of a sudden you appear
out of that and I was like oh my God Sam
is so sexy in this movie now like
complete pivot one one film we played
brother and sister everybody's fine with
Robert right and Kate beell that's right
that's right we played siblings yeah we
we played siblings and uh you remember
watching Bob work in the in the in the
hospital that day that was incredible
Robert being in a film with Robert dairo
that was was incredible that day in the
hospital he was just like laser man he
was remember that I will never forget
that was amazing do you know he un Les
he just worked with him he's like yeah
and they're best friends oh my God I I
need to ask her one time he was leaving
the set and he was like I got a
helicopter do you want to get a ride and
I was like nice yeah I didn't get the
helicopter well here's how I here was
how I responded yeah sure thanks are you
sure here was me inside
a are you scared of helicopters no I was
just psyched to be in the sky with
roero in any vehicle whatsoever you
could have shot me up in a tin can with
him and I'd have been like yeah what I
mean what else Sam like what do you
dream of now you've got this 17-
yearlong relationship you've got the
woman of your dreams who is having a
great life you have an Academy Award you
have lifelong friends sounds everybody
who loves you what the hell else is
there anything else you dream of or wish
for like what's what's can I take the
dog you want Douglas I mean no that's
that sounds pretty good on paper what
you just said right yeah I mean hell I
better enjoy
that well what's one thing that you
still wish for dream about you know I
think friends are really
the big thing you know you I mean for me
don't you think it's like that's your
family that's your you know cuz you and
I come from you know strange backgrounds
shall we say and then you know uh and we
always bonded about that we always knew
our friends were our family yeah yeah
and I think that's that's uh that's a
big deal you know we we both show we're
both show kids in in a different way but
I
mean and uh you know I think friends are
really important I think my without my
friends I'd be lost you know I can tell
you
as your friend and knowing all your
friends and you know dating one of your
friends for many many years like you are
a very good friend you are such a loyal
wonderful friend well it's a all right I
like this
audience well I love you I love you too
I love you as much as a human being can
love another human being love you so
much dog's getting
squished I love you too love you too um
Can We Dance our way out of theak yeah
let's dance I don't know how to not not
dance with you
Sam by the way our gu is out
everywhere and it's the best movie and
you're going to love
it
because you're the only one I can dance
with thank you everybody we'll be right
back
[Applause]
[Music]